the morning after a game that was
i don't i don't know i had no
expectations right i if we'd have taken
last night's game
everything about last night's game
and made it monday night's game between
the chiefs and the ravens we would have
said that was awesome right but because
it's the jets and the broncos peter it
was so hard to get excited about
anything that was happening even though
it was actually a pretty exciting game
well the problem with that game last
night is that a lot of it was exciting
because it was like a clown car
i i mean honestly
you know how many more penalties can the
jets commit
uh that'll hand denver real chances
that's what to me
was so
really weird about that game last night
so much happened so many opportunities
happened
out of
terrible plays
the the bizarre
pierre desire
uh bounced off his face mask touchdown
to jerry judy
and then
pierre dazir making one of the greatest
interceptions
that you're ever going to see
and in that exact same quarter pierre
dazir giving up four catches for 108
yards in one of the worst performances
by a cornerback in one quarter
in recent nfl history i mean
i
you know really after you watch that
game you need about four shots of
bourbon
during also i think is uh is advisable
to have something along those lines but
you know look the the jets for all the
criticism that they're not really trying
they were trying and they seemed to be
genuinely dejected when the game was
over there were shots of guys on the
sidelines they're upset that they lost
so these guys care they're just not good
enough that's the problem and that's the
philosophical issue that i think the
jets management has to deal with
how bad can you tolerate a team being
during a rebuild the panthers are
rebuilding they're not horrible the jets
are rebuilding
and they're horrible
and
at some point as i've said all week if
you're rebuilding you still have to be
able to live in the house and the jets
aren't and even though it was close and
even though nine points doesn't suggest
how close it really was and it came down
to the end and the jets could have won
it and there were you know there was a
comeback where the jets were down and
they had a couple of scores and they
took the lead so you know they didn't
they didn't fold the tents
but
they're all in four
and i'm looking at the schedule peter
and i don't see any wins
coming for the jets anytime soon
they're gonna be the underdogs in every
game until week 11 when their buy
arrives if they go 0-10
you know i know adam gase uh contrary to
some reporting from a radio host who
isn't really a reporter so it gives you
cover when you report something that's
wrong well i'm not a reporter i just
said what i heard well he heard he was
getting fired if he lost
he ain't getting fired
but i don't see any wins
i don't see i tell me a game peter
there's the schedule tell me a game that
you look at and say well i think the
jets have a good chance to win that one
maybe the chargers
maybe
maybe
you know here's the way i look at the
jets
you know
everything would be fine if
they were playing pretty good football
and being plucky
and disciplined and all that stuff
that was a horrendously undisciplined
football game last night
by the new york jets and just keep this
in mind
they're playing against a practice squad
quarterback
who
essentially
should never have been playing in this
game and would never have been playing
in this game if the two guys in front of
them hadn't gotten hurt
uh and so
you've got that part of it and they're
playing against
you know the new york jets are supposed
to have their franchise quarterback
and
you know look that was a valiant effort
by
sam darnold in some ways
and he's playing with probably practice
squad receivers too
but
the jets defense mike
you know 37 points
that weird bounce off melvin gordon
touchdown basically to clinch the game
i don't know you you have to tell me
is that
is that a team
that is representative of a team that
looks like
it's improving in any way shape or form
sure doesn't look like it to me
and peter because it's the defense that
that is committing these fouls and
causing these problems
you know to the extent that there is any
sort of contemplation of making an
in-season coach coaching change how do
you justify making greg williams the
defensive coordinator of the interim
head coach that that may save gates for
the year in and of itself who do you
give the whistle to
if you tell adam gase this just isn't
working
the only way you justify it is you say
essentially well adam gase was five and
three as an interim coach it's like i
was telling somebody yesterday it's like
damning with faint praise he was five
and three as an interim coach
and
he's you know he can make something out
of chaos
and mike i don't care how bad the
defense is playing right now i just i
don't think that that team is responding
to adam gase at all
and i don't disagree with that and
that's what's unfortunate and that's
what's going to potentially
short-circuit the effort to rebuild the
team he inherited a team
that
did not have a good roster
mike mccagnin was building the team from
the outside in instead of the inside out
joe douglas has flipped it around and is
trying to build from the inside out for
example you don't go out and spend 13.5
million per year on a running back when
you otherwise don't have an offense to
let the running back do what the running
back is being paid to do
and as sims said yesterday in only the
way that chris sims can christian
hackenberg one of the worst second round
picks of all time sims claims he can
throw better with his other hand than
christian hackenberg ever could throw
with his good hand and
and and and this is what you know maybe
gates just shouldn't have taken the job
you know maybe instead of rebounding
after getting fired by the dolphins he
just should have said i'm i'm gonna pick
my next spot a little more carefully but
the bottom line is
you have to be
competitive
in a rebuild you can't just shut it down
you can't just suck
and they're they're lucky that they
don't have to worry about fans showing
up or not showing up for their games but
who's watching the games i've seen that
the ratings for the jets in new york
have been abysmal and i i i can see why
i mean
even the teams that rebuild
are are there's a sense they're trying
there's a sense they're doing their best
and maybe these guys are doing their
best
but it just there's something that's
missing between this team and other
teams i've seen that are acknowledged to
be in rebuilding mode peter and maybe it
is they're just not responding to the
coach and if that's the case he'd better
fix it soon
or it really isn't sustainable if they
go 0 and 10 into the bye week how do you
justify not making it how do you do it
how can you do how can you tell anyone
who gives a crap about new york jets
football we're just going to go ahead
and ride this out for the final six
games and and hope that we get lucky and
win one
mike um
you know there there will be talk soon
there already is talk show talk in new
york about okay who's the next coach
and i would just ask you let's say
you name a coach right now
robert sala
you know eric b enemy you name who i i
don't know who the hot coach is going to
be this coming off season
all right but
i believe that if if a promising hot
coach
has an option
you know has maybe jets and falcons or
jets and you know who whoever whoever it
turns out to be
if they have an option
you got to look at a number of things
i would look at the cap situation i'd be
afraid of atlanta
um you got to look at you got to look at
everything
but
you know
if you were to take the jets job you
would have to have faith in two things
above all else number one joe douglas
because joe douglas is going to be there
he is a good personnel guy and the jets
should just stand back and let joe
douglas make these calls that's number
one number two
you know you have to really really love
trevor lawrence or some quarterback in
this draft
or you have to love sam darnold to the
point that
you will say hey let's get a couple of
ones and trade down we'll keep sam darn
it we'll use those ones to help the
rebuild
so
those are the things you have to love
because i'm just telling you
there
you know there are so many things that
are wrong with the new york jets
and both in personnel
ownership everything
that right now
if you have a choice you have to
seriously consider the other choice
and i know that there's a popular belief
that joe douglas is safe he signed the
six-year contract i get it i understand
it but let's remember when mike mckagne
was fired the first name that came up
was joe douglas because the belief was
that was adam gases hand-picked guy so
if gase goes i don't know that douglas
has the automatic security especially if
peter
woody is back at some point in the next
six months and woody decides i'm just
going to hit the reset button and i'm
going to start over and i'm going to
tell my brother christopher thanks for
everything get the hell out i've got
this from here which introduces a new
set of dynamics that really haven't been
discussed nationally the way that maybe
they should woody may be back and we
don't know what what he's going to do
when he gets back we do know what sam
darnold did last night i got to give him
credit i got to give him credit he got
slammed to the ground early and i know
mike pereira
said on twitter he didn't think that
should draw a foul i look at it more
from the you know it when you see it and
we hear all the time about not throwing
the quarterback to the ground he got
thrown to the ground i was surprised
that wasn't flagged and it was obvious
that he was banged up but he came back
and he played he wasn't horrible but he
wasn't great i mean look
the guy who was the third overall pick
in the draft the guy they traded up
three spots to get should have been able
to outdo brett riffen should have with
everything yeah all other things
relatively equal it's not like the
broncos have this murderer's row and
here comes the undrafted guy from boise
state
to to complement a great lineup all
other things were relatively equal
plenty of injuries for the broncos
sam donald should have been able to win
that game and and you know i look great
he came back he had the great touchdown
run before he got injured 84 rushing
yards the most ever for a jets
quarterback in any game i don't know
whether that's good or whether that's
bad
but uh he had 54 more rushing yards than
the next leading rusher on the team last
night but you know it's pass fail and
when you lose you fail and you know sam
darnold for whatever reason he hasn't
become the guy that that we remember
there was a time
2016
2017.
oh he's the first overall pick in the
draft oh without without question he's
the guy he's going to be great he's the
can't miss guy and and i've yet to see
anything from him consistently that
makes me think that that this is a
franchise quarterback that's going to be
in the nfl for 15 years
you're right mike but he made a couple
of throws last night
um
you know and again i keep coming back to
you have to figure out
how in the world you were going to judge
a quarterback
when he's throwing to guys and mike i i
have to tell you
you know there's a couple of guys he's
throwing to last night who i could who
aren't absolute football fans
fantasy football nerds
matthew barry
has not heard of these guys
they just showed up and put on jets
uniforms and again you know so so you
you see some of the great plays that he
made last night and you say to yourself
well
the old bill walsh theory i remember a
long time ago around 86 or 87
i'm doing a story
on bill walsh in the old 49ers now this
is about 90.
because i was at sports illustrated but
i'm doing a story on bill walsh and how
he drafts
and
bill walsh had this saying
inside his draft room if i've seen a guy
do it a couple of times
we can coach him to do it all the time
and that's why they drafted charles
haley out of james madison when
everybody said charles haley he didn't
even dominate at the 108 level why are
we picking this guy in the third round
there's a lot better players there and
bill walsh saw a couple of plays on
video or on film that he loved out of
charles haley and he was right
so now you ask yourself this question
do you have the faith
in
sam darnold to believe that when you see
some of the incredibly good plays he
makes that you can train him to do it
all the time or
you know did you hear troy aikman last
night he was obsessing about this one
play early on i think it was the first
quarter
where he had the guy cager i think it
was
open with a step on the corner and he
was doing a crossing route and there was
nothing but air in front of him and he
never threw the ball
and aikman was really critical of of of
darnold for that and i agree there have
been a lot of instances where he
automatically is taking the check down
or taking the easier throw
those are the things you have to ask
yourself can we coach them out of this
or is this just a symptom of a guy who's
never going to be great
enough from us on sam darnold here is
what coach adam gase and darnold himself
had to say last night after the jets
lost to the denver broncos
i mean we called a ton of passes we we
were not very effective in the run game
which we we got made one-dimensional and
when that happens then
you know
we're we're gonna give up until the
quarterback we got to do a better job
stepping up and picking up the blitzes
when they when they did pressure with
our backs and
we just didn't do a good enough job
do you feel that the team made some
progress tonight being in the game all
the way to the end of the game as
opposed to the first three games
i mean we got to win games man that's
you know i guess
yeah it's better than getting blown out
but we gotta win that game
[Music]
yeah and look i i i agree they didn't
embarrass themselves but you could argue
it's an embarrassment in and of itself
to lose by nine points at home to a
broncos team that has none of its key
players available to it no von miller no
drew lock no cortland sutton noah fan
got injured during the game
they are just one injury after another
and i we got to give the broncos some
credit for finding a way to show up and
win the game on a short week it would
have been very easy for them to fold
tents right both teams could have mailed
this one in
traveling from denver to new york city
in a pandemic and it's a short week and
we stink and it's not going to get any
better and we got to deal with the
chiefs in our division ah who cares so i
got to give them credit they've played
hard see that's the difference that's
the difference the broncos have played
hard the broncos have had chances the
broncos haven't been blown off the field
their ugliest game was sunday's game
against the buccaneers and this is how
they rebounded from it and that's the
difference
that that's that that's and i you know
the broncos aren't necessarily
rebuilding they're just waiting for guys
to come back
but you have to find a way in the
national football league to be
competitive no matter what the
circumstances are no matter who you're
down to on the depth chart and that gets
back to our original point it doesn't
feel sustainable i i feel like adam gase
has been dealt a bad hand
but
sometimes you got to make it work even
if your hand is you know high card seven
of diamonds
you know here's the other question mike
about the jets
why was mckay beckton in that game
i mean really i guess it was sort of
marginal whether he should play or
whether he shouldn't play but then he
plays for whatever 15 snaps i don't know
how many he played and you could see him
on the bench
you know when when the fox cameras or
nfl network cameras were looking at him
like
he was either in pain or about to cry
i mean he just he looked terrible
and he looked terrible he looked unhappy
he looked pissed he looked down happy
yeah yeah yeah like what whatever
whatever it was
why was i in this game
whatever it was whatever it was there's
a good chance a good chance
that beckton now has been set back so
when will he play
there might be your best offensive
player through through the first month
of the season
and now he might be out just like
you know all the other guys on your team
are out so again
you know look how do you judge this
really how do you judge this fairly
the only thing i know is that i don't
see a team responding to its head coach
that's the only thing that i see
everything else you know who should be
interim coach i mean who cares really if
they make a change
you know but it's one of those things
this isn't working let's try the best
other possible option
and you mentioned that greg williams was
five and three as an interim head coach
a few years ago with the cleveland
browns didn't get the job when the dust
settled the personal fouls last night
created a problem both for the jets when
it comes to winning the game but also
after the game ended vic fangio exited
the field quickly hustled his guys off
no handshakes no conversation no small
talk and it created a buzz on social
media because the thinking was that that
he was deliberately snubbing adam gase
because he was mad at gays himself and
some people said well no he's just being
safe because we're in a pandemic well
both fangio and gates addressed the
situation after the game here's what
they both had to say
well there just was a couple personal
files there at the end and our our
sideline was getting uh pissed off about
it and i just wanted to avoid any
confrontation at the end of the game and
having it get ugly there so i
tried to get our guys to leave quickly
just to avoid anything happening there
i thought it was the prudent thing to do
i heard vic yelling at this guy saying
get it get in the locker room so i i saw
what was going on were you guys pissed
off about something or was he pissed off
about something like that running i
think he was just trying to make sure we
didn't have any kind of
melee
you know it was getting heated
you know melee is a word that doesn't
get used nearly enough i appreciate adam
gase adding to the lexicon and also
every time
what about ruckus
brouhaha
here's the other thing too peter anytime
that i say the phrase pissed off on this
program i always hesitate for a split
second beforehand thinking i really
shouldn't be saying it but you know if
we're going to use it in the press
conference and the reporter's asking the
question twice and it comes up then i
guess that's the green light we can say
pissed off when whenever we don't have
to worry about somebody being pissed off
if we say pissed off i guess is what i'm
saying
yeah i think um our current level of uh
discourse in this country
where after the debate the other night
uh a very respected commentator used the
sh word uh describing what the debate
was i think it's okay if you say pissed
off mike that's
that's that's where we are in this
country right now
oh a very unrespected football analyst
has used the sh word on this program i
think once or twice not you not me
somebody with blonde would he be blonde
in about 6'5
yes with a giant head and with a history
of kicking mulch into his father's
swimming pool that is him yes
christopher christopher
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports